Is she- Is she dead ?
*scream*
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome to Welcome to Hanwell.
Hi! I didn't notice you back there!
Did you do all this work ? I love it ! It's.. very Jackson Pollocky with all the blood... he's the guy that did the splatter paintings.
Oooh...
In loving memory of Graham Foster.
Oh~
That's actually a memorial
I mean kind of sweet in the juxtaposition of what will be a horror game, but I like it nonetheless
So this one I found... um...I actually can't remember where I found it
It was mysteriously installed on my desktop, and I have no idea why or how it appeared there
But I guess we're just waking up in a bed again, a little bit of a cliche among horror games
I can't move my--oh there we go, hello.
I can see again. Ah, I love the drab decor!
Helloo?
I'm trapped and scared and alone and- what the fuck is that sound?
[afraid Mark face]
Hi! Okay, hello...
[silent hair karate]
Oh ok. Bye then
You just- You just gonna leave me here?
alOne
In the darkness, in the murder corridor
This is where people die!
Hello?
Ok, alright then.
I'll just be here...
...alone...
Ooooh!
Goooooooood!
You know now that freedom is an option,  I don't even know if I want to get out
Oh, okay, all right mysterious noises
Mysterious door. 'This area is out of service until further notice.'
Oh good. They spray-painted that across the bars. Very good, and I love the trail of blood
Ohhhhh...k do I need to do that right now, or is that like an eventually kind of thing?
Eugh... okay...
Oh yeah, that's working properly. Alright that's good. Alright, decrepit, very nice? Oh hey.. Hi!
Hi, how are you doing? Are you in timeout?
What did you do? Were you bad?
I bet you were if your time-out in a jail cell. Holy shit, must be the worst of the worst
Ew
Destitute. Oh is that a head? Is that a head in a fridge?
That's a head in a fridge. Isn't it? Just gonna close that up there. No one needs to see that; Alright. Hello?
Joe the phone broke I need to get on the warden about why we're down here stuck with all this shit falling apart when the
suits upstairs get a brand new office. Plus, these guys are getting impatient; half of them haven't even had a trial
I'm leaving early. Well all right then, asshole.
[  questionable telephone noises ]
I think you've got the wrong number. Ew, okay then all righty ho
[Mark makes disgusted face, strange pseudo-piano-ballad plays in background]
Huh?
Eh!
[music gets louder] Why is Creed playing in the bathroom?
Okay, all right then
I'm gonna get out of here. There was no point in me coming in here. Oh boy all right whoo
Okay, all right. Fucking hi!
Oh, it's just a swinging light, and I've seen that before. You about to illuminate someone in time out again?
Eugh...
Hi! Okay...
Alrighty then subtle. I like it
Subtle! I mean I'm waiting for the eventual extreme scare in my face, but subtle! Good stuff
Oh! Fa--uckin' hi--okay bye.
Was it a ghost?
Okay, not very scary, not scary. Not what I call spooky but uh pretty good nonetheless
Okay, nevermind then door number three
[Creepy recording plays]
"-immense pressure at the moment,  trying to contain the anomalies emerging from the research center after a failed operation to plug the gate
Early reports suggest substantial loss of life"
"Meanwhile in Hanwell Jail many opportunistic prisoners used the confusion and scant resources to their advantage
Escaping through a weak point in the recreation yard. The doctor could not be contacted when we reached out for a statement
Okay, thank you radio of exposition
So glad that you were there to help me along my journey. I feel much. Oh, hey
Okay, I got a key
'Sir, it's John'
'My guards are getting tired of the usual shit down here'
'The refills there didn't help'
'They can- they can see the money coming in, but in their minds it's being spent on luxuries for you upstairs,'
'as opposed to vital equipment down here, in the cells'
'We may be looking at a strike if we're not careful'
'You know we just can't afford that the council on high alert'
'Also, the doctor has requested two more inmates'
'I've- I've had to decline'
'None of these guys have had a trial. Can't hand them over, he may as well be picking people off the street'
'Get back to me'
Well that's nice there
there seems to be someone that has some semblance of justice in this weird world that we're in
But I don't know, seems like they're doing the--the standard--
[Creepy noises]
Why? Why?? Why would you do that? Why would you do that to me? Why would you do that. Fucking hi!
[Clanking Noises]
Again, I would like to say: Why would that be a thing that needs to happen now?
Okay  then ah
Good yes burner is becoming an issue in Littlewood. Criminals using an anomalous activity to cover up
burglaries. Witch ghoul breeder
transferred? What kind of world do we live in?
Ok, so if I'm not, if I'm not mistaken
this is ah
This is where we just were. Wait that one's locked, but there's an arrow pointing down right by that bathroom
But it was just a bunch of lockers over there, so does that mean that there's like a secret door over there?
Ooooh...
Mmkay, ugh. Wha' is a witch breeder?
Oh! Hello. Oh good its development of the game. Oh, that's kind of clever
I like that. Anything else on these? No? All right. Council fallen, Hanwell compromised--by D.
Octir. The doctor is dead. The Council has fallen.
We are all trapped within these
concrete slabs of grey oppression. Where we go from here is unclear but Hanwell is no longer the bastion of living anymore
Okay, it didn't feel like a bastion of safe living as it stands now
So why would it be then? Okay; All right?
Then you know what I'm ah take this key, and I'm gonna find where it goes to
Is it this door? Hello?
It is. ...Hi...oh, tha--
[gasp] Hey...
Okay, all right then. Oh can I let the person out of timeout?
Can I let them out of time out? That seems like it'd be a bad idea
Okay, all right, then. You know what I'm gonna go for it.
Never mind. I didn't want to do all of them. Oh
Time out lady
No, No, No, No, No, No, No, No, No, No, No, No, No, No, No, No, No, No, No, No, No, No, No, No, No
Don't think you can do that to me
You think you can do that to me? You think you can just do that to me? Huh? DO YOU KNOW WHO I AM?
Do you know how many horror games I've screamed at?
To minor to moderate effectiveness, huh?
You think I won't scream at you?
Okay, there was something in here before but apparently not now, okay. These showers are lovely
Oooh. Fuck, thought I saw something.
All right, come on
Who be there, huh?
someone's going back in the naughty corner
real soon
Okay, so was there something behind this? No. It seems like there might have been at some point
Okay, here we go, skedaddling
Eee. Glad to know that's still malfunctioning. So why were you--and I know it's probably not a good idea to go in that cell--
But why were you in timeout?
Huh, why?
Ok fucking, hi
Hello?
Hello??
Hi, ok all right, then. I'm gonna go to the out of service area covered in oceans of blood. Oh, this is a bad hallway
Something's behind me, isn't it?
Hey! Okay. All right then everything's fine
Freedom this way. Oh, I believe you. I believe you with all my heart if you can get past the bitch
I'm gonna assume you meant to write witch, Oh
alrighty then
I've got a flashlight and a bang banger. I'm all swang swang my bang banger up against your skull, put you in timeout...
Forever!
Permanently!
Oh.
[ragged breathing]
Fucking...
Do I... Is she-Is she dead? Is she dead?
Ah! NO!
[Sigh of relief]
Alrighty then... Crouching eliminates the sound of your footsteps.
Hmm--aaah!
I don't like that. Oh, no. Oh is this poop on the floor?
[sounds of a woman crying]
Uaahhh...
Uaahoh...
Aaaauuuuahaah...
Eeaaaughhhg...UUUUGAAHUAUAUAUAUA!!!
Go faster crouchy crew!! Oh; what is up my crouchy crew? Oh!
AHHHH!!!
Nah nah nah nah nah nah nah. How 'bout no? How 'bout no? How 'bout NO ?!
Ah fuck! Woah!
Well that didn't work.
I think she pushed. I think she bumped me into the tunnel that I was supposed to be in but somehow that didn't work...
Oddly enough...
Hey!
*distressed mark noises*
I'ma go down here. I'll go down here down here. Yes. Yes yes yes. Yes. Yes, it worked!
I think. Maybe? I don't know
Hello, ah I seem to have left my crow-BAR.
Alrighty then.
At least I'm going down to this Amnesia-esque hallway of
Caverns and Tunnels
But where's it gonna lead me, down at the bottom? And ALSO...
There's something about a witch breeder...? Like, what does that even mean?
Like Ah- [snake like noises]
Hey, you know after I just encountered a ghost lady
You think snakes are actually gonna bother me or scorpions or whatever the hell that was? Huh?
I'm a big strong brave boy. You ain't gonna mess with me
[hissing growl sound] Okay, that's not as good as I thought it was gonna be
[sound gets closer] That's actually the opposite of good
Ahh! That's actually the opposite of good. I'm gonna just skedaddle this way. Don't mind me. I just like to skedaddle with great frequency
Excuse my spit
[high-pitched shrieking sound] Ahh! Fucking-
Is that the end yeah, you gonna do a-you gonna do a- Yeah, that's the end okay
All right, then Nathan Seedhouse. I see how you be
Okay, so anyway that was
Welcome to Hanwell. It's pretty good. I gotta admit. They did a pretty good job here
There's actually good animation work. Good environment work. Good potential for something good here. So
like with all these demos. I'm gonna go ahead and say I would like to see a lot more of this game
But I don't know when that's going to be so either way
Thank you everybody so much for watching
I'll put a link to this game down the comments or the description below and hopefully I can find more about this game
later on, but--hope you guys enjoyed it. Let me know what you think and as always I will see you...
In the next video. Bye bye!
[Horror outro]